I'm retiring well in that case what are
we drinking same for the goddaughter God
told me you found something
trained during the war
dial that could change the course of
history why are you chasing the thing
that drove your father crazy
he'll move please get out of here
sorry
did yours get him
[Music]
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all you stole it then
you stole it and then I stole it it's
called capitalism
[Music]
starting your seat belt there might be
some tablets you've taken your chances
made your mistakes
and now a final Triumph
India give him hell Indiana Jones a few
times in my life I've seen things
I'm gonna torture with Voodoo
been shot nine times
included once by your father
ah sorry
but I've been looking for this
all my life
[Music]